thank you Jovi we are indeed with Google
nova after a big victory for her tell us
a bit about this game tell us a bit
about this matchup you know Katarina
quite well you've played her before how
do you feel about this matchup and
today's game
I'm pretty comfortable with her because
I have been playing like for some reason
many games since uh like 2021 so I'm
comfortable and I believe she's
comfortable because we know each other
well
so and the game started like pretty
badly for her she just got a little bit
like that structure and I had space more
space and it was easier for me to play
and after Bishop G4 here and after
Bishop E2 I was surprised that she took
on F3 I thought she's gonna take twice
and then she or she can take only two
yeah that's true only two would be
better I guess but she took on F3 and
then she played Bishop E7 so I thought
when she took on uh through at least
like instead of Bishop E7 C5 would be
better because if I attack on C6 right
now you can take him yeah
go C5 I mean at least she has some like
compensation for the bishop right I felt
like Knight on D4 is
um like strong but after Bishop E7
we should be true I don't think now she
had to play that after I'm taking on C6
she cannot take with the pawn so she
needs to attack back she doesn't have
enough time she has to interpose this
check Knight takes F3 the problem is
that this structure is just very bad
yeah it's very bad at some point I I
think I could play even C5 and sacrifice
the
like before maybe before yeah here even
like I was thinking of it instead of you
see one okay like C5 C5 take and just
just to play this game Rook C1 Knight A4
B3 but I wasn't sure because Rook B8
Rook B4 and she would start attacking my
E4 Pawn even though I had like Knight C5
and she she's not on time to take my E4
Pawn I wasn't sure it felt like even
after C5 I have a very comfortable play
one thing that I noticed is that she was
spending a lot of time and you were
maintaining your lid on the clock uh did
you feel that was part of your strategy
as well no it's just easier for me to
play this position I know my like moves
right and for her she needs to come up
with something for example G6 all these
like ideas with F5 maybe at some point
she had to push F5 instead of 57 it felt
like and then uh at this point at five
yeah
I was going to play F3 right
yeah and I was thinking of G4 at some
point that I could play for you okay
yeah not to give F5 at all but I was
like I'm beginning my king I I already
have a weakness remember what your coach
told you don't weaken your king anymore
all right I was like my coach is gonna
attack me so let's stay on G2 okay very
good you did the right thing
um and when did you feel like you're
pretty much wrapping up the game taking
over actually when I found this idea
Rook H1 and slowly G3 F4 F5 everything
is coming and I was very annoyed that I
played uh King D3 because uh initially
my initial idea was to play King F3 and
then I was like wait a sec let let's put
the king there so after Knight C7 Knight
E6 I won't have Knight G5 or Knight D4
checks right at all but like it was too
General I could I could just play King
F3 King Knight E3 Knight F5 and I could
take on D6 yeah unlike that position
with the King on D3 when you take on D6
you have some pins that's why I was a
little bit uh annoyed and I felt like
her King was moving back and I felt it's
a little bit harder but she just didn't
have time and she blundered ge5 and G6
after and time indeed was off the
essence she finished with only two
minutes on the clock a big victory for
you to start off uh your campaign here
at the American Cup uh what are your
aspirations let's say for for this event
School taking a lot of my time just you
I'm doing my internship too so I haven't
been playing that much I feel I feel
like I haven't been playing for like a
year or two I was so away from from
Chelsea in general from Chess World so
it's good to be back and play some chess
congratulations we'll see you tomorrow
thank you our congratulations as well
very nice game we do have a Lavon